it would seem
that if anybody
had justification for an exemption from
a mandate
it would have to be you
you are sensitive at the level that it
will produce an anaphylactic reaction to
a component of two of the vaccines
you are sensitive to a wide number of
things making any injection a risk
and the third vaccine to which you have
access has a component to which you
might be cross-reactive so
fair to say that it would clearly put
your life in jeopardy to take one of
these vaccines
yeah definitely yeah
so
uh what happened when you uh went to the
doctor and said i can't take these uh i
need an exemption
yeah so given that our mandates were
coming in and every um occupation being
on the mandate list i was like well if i
don't have my exemption i legally can't
work in the state of victoria
um now that's also gone across
nationwide so there's not any state i
would be able to
over the next few months given the
mandates and again you are you are a
caterer working out of
a
catering vehicle
so yeah into this is not
uh a situation where you're
tending to patients indoors
and enclosed spaces you're
working pretty close to outdoors with
respect to your interface with anybody
else and yet you you can't work without
uh proof of vaccination
no i can't even if i'm in the space by
myself and even if it's a door down
operation and i'm just literally even
doing
click and collect or contactless um
delivery
i'm still
not legally allowed to work
um in my home state all right and i
interrupted you were gonna tell me what
happened when you uh you went to your
doctor to ask for the exemption that you
were obviously due
yeah so i i went to my gp who
knows my history um
she
i have quite an extensive history so my
file is quite a big one if say i were to
take to a new specialist or a new doctor
um
so i went to her just thinking it'll be
an easy process it's stipulated on
multiple government websites so if
you've got a contraindication and a
polyethylene specifically a polyethylene
glycol
excipient allergy and the high
possibility of polysorbate 80 cross
reactivity you can be granted a
permanent exemption
to the covert vaccinations
so
given that this was stipulated on um
multiple websites in australia the um
[Music]
the
victorian specialist immunization
services the melbourne
vaccination education center's website
um i know even globally it's been
mentioned on the cdc website and
numerous ones as well
um
it's also uh stipulated on the
australian immunization registrar the
form which is the form that the doctors
fill out that gets sent to our medicare
to be able to be granted this
permanent exemption
so i went to my doctor asking her to
fill out this form it's called the im011
form
she returned to me with saying
i can't give you the exemption due to
legal liability
wow
that's that's incredible
all right so
i i still can't quite wrap my mind
around any system that has so little
discretion in it that someone whose
story is as clear as yours and for whom
the jeopardy is as severe as the
jeopardy that you face
can't get an exemption
presumably
uh
you didn't take
no for an answer
um
what else has happened
well since that i was quite
i was quite perplexed by that it didn't
seem to make any sense that she would
have
she said that she couldn't grant me an
exemption due to legal liability
um it's also stipulated on all these
websites the people that can
um
administer an exemption are general
practitioners clinical immunologists
obstetricians gynecologists
pediatricians
um
so it was like well clear as day to me
i've got the contraindication you're my
general practitioner you know this
you're my trading doctor
why can't you submit this form and she
just kept saying that no i can't there's
too many legalities around it and then
she also said to me the only people that
can
were a clinical immunologist
so from there i
asked for a referral to my previous
clinical immunologist which was through
a public health care system at a public
um hospital
these were the people who actually
diagnosed me six years ago with the
polyethylene glycol allergy
um
i got back a letter from the hospital
saying that the weight would be 12 to 24
months before i could see a clinical
immunologist
wow
so
uh you know i must say i obviously knew
your story before we started talking
each time i hear it i find myself newly
shocked
and enraged
i mean
we have
two amazing facts already on the table
one the idea that legal liability
actually
causes someone not to want to give you
the exemption
which is of course
the exact inverse of what you would
expect right the fact that your life
will be placed in jeopardy by taking
such a vaccination if there's any place
where there should be
legal liability it would be that a
practitioner that failed to give you the
exemption is putting your life in in
jeopardy and yet
there is some other kind of jeopardy
that frightens this practitioner
even more
and then as you go to the authority that
you're told is the only authority who
can grant the exemption
you're told it will take 12 months did
you say
12 to 24 months yeah
a year to two years during which time
you will not be able
to work
wouldn't be able to work and participate
in like many facets of society as well
so you would basically
lose
fundamental rights including the right
to earn a living
because you can't get an exemption
that frankly anyone should understand is
absolutely justified
this is um
i mean it's tragic and it's also
in some sense a measure of just how
dysfunctional
the west has become
you know i i know
australia is in some sense
ahead of
the curve with respect to
authoritarian measures with response to
covid but
this is just
it's a
it's a stunning
rejection of the idea of a functional
system it's the inverse of a functional
system
all right so you took you were told you
would take 12 to 24 months to get the
exemption that would then allow you to
return
to work
what happened next
so
i went back to my doctor and told her
this is the correspondence i received um
from the hospital it was in written
letter form
[Music]
earlier to this i also have a
private pain specialist um he is who i
see for um about my alice dunlop
syndrome and other conditions
he had noted he was the first one to
actually note that there might be mast
cell activation
issues
um
and that he would recommend me to see a
private clinical immunologist
so i asked my doctor if she could refer
me to him thinking possibly the weight
could be a lot shorter um i just thought
given that my history had been with this
other hospital it was probably best to
go see them however i'm happy to go
private
right because the other hospital
because they diagnosed the condition in
the first place before their before
covet existed
they obviously know that you couldn't
possibly be making this up
right i mean no one has better evidence
of that than that hospital and yet and
yet they couldn't see the necessity of
getting you
an exemption i mean frankly a piece of
paper that just simply
stops this train in motion
it's incredible
exactly yeah so i um i requested to see
a a private specialist who i've never
seen before
um
which i found out that the wait to see
them would be 11 months
um
i i i
i have to ask you this betty
is there any way
that you're just
being too nice when people tell you
these
incredible things are you saying to them
are you looking them in the eye and are
you saying
i am a human being i am entitled not to
have my livelihood destroyed and my life
put in jeopardy and you're telling me i
have to wait a year or more in order to
even see the specialist who can write
the exemption can you please help me
have you said something like that
with my i guess my main point of call is
being my general practitioner um
and
to hear her say that she couldn't grant
me an exemption
was quite shocking then to find out
these wait times
i thought no i just need to go back to
her and i need to reiterate how
important this is
um
so i did once i found out about this
weight and i thought i'm going to do
this again and i don't care that she
said no the first time i'm going to ask
um
possibly i have been quite nice and
not maybe as assertive
previously i guess prior to this i
didn't think there would be any issue of
me gaining an exemption it just seemed
very clear-cut that i was going to be
the perfect candidate
to gain an exemption given my history
um and what has been stipulated
everywhere on the government websites
and the health websites that i thought
oh this is easy for people like me
um especially given that it's been noted
that a polyethylene glycol
excipient allergy is a very rare case
um
not to mention across all of our
media platforms our mainstream media
platforms
the constant message
being said is
not everyone can get vaccinated
and
essentially people like myself so the
ones who can't get vaccinated are being
used
in this way um
call it propaganda if you will but they
are literally saying
get vaccinated for those who can't
yes this is this is also my thought is
it would seem
[Music]
the propaganda here too
says look not everybody is lucky enough
to be able to accept this vaccine not
everyone can take it it is the
obligation of those who can to do it for
the vulnerable
who can't
now if the system
is not giving you an exemption if it
doesn't understand you as somebody in
need of protection
presumably from both covid and the
vaccines
then who is this for
who are we protecting if not you
exactly and that's why all this
exemption process just seemed to make no
sense to me because it just felt like
well what what is the good of the
exemptions
if they're not granting them
for people like me or it is near
impossible to be granted this
so i returned to my doctor and requested
again i said look
the mandates are coming in that was that
week i said the mandates are coming in
this week
i cannot legally earn a living
um
i was also told that i may not be able
to um
see my psychologist in person
um due to this so i'm also being denied
access
to other health industries um
there are some doctors that are refusing
to see patients
um especially face to face they're doing
tele health but face to face if they're
not vaccinated
um you're being denied access to
important aspects of civilization
including
health care
by virtue of the fact that you can't get
an exemption to which you were obviously
entitled and i must say in my own
defense i did not mean to suggest that
there's any part of me
that thinks any of the responsibility
here is on you even if you're being too
nice it is the obligation of other human
beings to understand what has to take
place here in order for the right
outcome to occur
these are people who have the power to
write an exemption
yes and somehow are not
providing it to you
though
we're literally i mean we're literally
talking about an issue of
your ability not only to earn a living
but to survive
yeah that's
exactly it is a stunning failure of
um
these people's obligation to a fellow
human being it just
it boggles the mind
[Music]
you